street food gets its name because it's
cooked and eaten on the streets from the
hawker markets in asia to the new york
hot dog stands there are some great
chefs out there serving seriously
delicious food that you can eat on the
go
my first recipe is a special mix of
fantastic flavors from around the world
beef tacos with wasabi mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the only rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix a mexican and
japanese flavours into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
i'll add flavor
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
give the pan a
little shake and it stops the steak from
sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now
two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soy bean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary kick
couple of tablespoons of olive oil
salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little base all
we're doing every time is just adding
more more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really
melt all that fat down
off of the gas
take them out
just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are
um chinese cabbages slice it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
you think of cabbage here and you think
of sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness
a little season chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
a couple of tablespoons of mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the gas ring
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
look at that really nice
sear around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my
crispy shell
back of the spoon with the wasabi
mayonnaise
inside taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
touch more
on my spicy
layer
and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
spicy mexican soup
it's hearty delicious robust but served
with some tortillas and a wonderful
salsa it's almost like a complete meal
in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early these
are chipotle so they're smoky rich they
don't come with any warning signal and
these are seriously hot so be
adventurous
but beware
a nice teaspoon
of toasted cumin
oregano dried
now start frying off spices the heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious
garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic
are on fire
we're gonna balance the sort of heat
from the chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat
and really start caramelizing that sugar
and the chili
gives off the most amazing
aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy
so
cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release chilis
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hot it will be
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet
and every five six seven eight minutes
that's gonna get stronger
hotter and more delicious
bring that up to the bowl and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst i allow the chili heat to infuse
i'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceeded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion then chop a good
handful of fresh coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop bought
wheat wraps
[Music]
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and leave to cool
to complete my mexican lunch i need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spice is there
it is
absolutely spot on
now for the cooling down process
the mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilies and spices but they're
also experts at tempering their dishes
with cooling ingredients like avocado
sour cream and cheese that's why you can
take that amount of chili you'll have a
spoon of richness spice and all of a
sudden avocados
almost like a little fire blanket over
those chilies
to further counter the chilli heat
mexicans use a rich tangy crumbly cheese
but i'm sprinkling on lancashire which
is a great british substitute
and last but not least
cooling fresh coriander one delicious
spicy mexican soup
serve that with your tortilla chips and
your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess
big bold spicy mexican eggs
this is a very classic mexican style
brunch dish
bold kick-ass flavors slice the chili
seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
a tablespoon of olive oil
i'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch can see you
right through to dinner now to start the
sort of spicy fragrant tomato sauce get
your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
never embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes i do all the time cooking at
home
now by reducing that you sort of come
down to a delicious paste
leave that to simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb
leaving the dense beans to luxuriate in
the spicy tomato sauce will allow them
to soften and soak up all the flavor
next oil and season an ovenproof dish
from my spicy egg brunch to baking
now just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix
and place that on top of the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps i want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into there
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
montgomery cheddar i wanna grate the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top
i'm going to season that with these
little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon
and they're going to spice up that egg
just salt
a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes
and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
a little bit of coriander to finish it
off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy mexican eggs and a
crispy tortilla shell